[Musique]
Jocelyne David Alexis Dora c'est Daniel
pilon ont tous en commun d'avoir un
parcours de vie qui ne les prédestinait
pas à devenir policier pour combattre la
corruption dans les
rangsc je vais travailler à peu près
toute ma vie dans le domaine des
finances
ces nouvelles recrues fraîchement
diplômés de l'empq en décembre dernier
font partie de la première corde de
nouvelle formation permettant à des gens
de tout âge de joindre du pack comme
policier reconnu par la loi saison les
compétences nécessaires pour lutter
contre la corruption bon nombre d'entre
eux faisaient déjà de la lutte contre la
corruption avant d’amorcer ce virage
professionnels financiers depuis
plusieurs années si certains que j'ai dû
avoir une discussion avec mon conjoint
avant vraiment d'accepter le poste
d'enquêteurs ici j'avais déjà un
background de finances et en dessous de
tout une en spécialisé dans le domaine
financier et de le faire en devenant
policier si vous l'auriez deviné un jour
que votre parcours de vie vous amène
vraiment non pas vraiment faut vraiment
ça c'était un petit peu une surprise
dans ma vie disons pour d'autres c'est
le début d'une toute nouvelle carrière
je suis original de l'Europe de l'Est de
la Moldavie donc c'est ça j'ai immigré
avec mes parents quand j'étais un peu
plus jeunes
j'avais 4 ans en Europe de l'Est la
corruption malheureusement comme pas mal
présente puis je voulais m'assurer
justement que dans notre communauté ici
au Canada que justement que la lutte
contre la corruption soit faite avec des
gens professionnels ce programme de
recrutement de 600 heures répartis sur
15 semaines est venu régler le problème
de pénurie de policiers on avait une
douzaine de postes d'hiver jusqu'à mon
comme un personne vont démontrer
l'intérêt puis toujours la question de
savoir soulever un bon québécois puis
finalement très 300 candidatures tous
les candidats retenus sont embauchés par
l'UPAC c'est donc dire qu'il reçoive
leur salaire à tenter de sergent
enquêteur durant les 9 semaines de
formation obligatoire au collège à
inseek et 6 autres à le NPQ de plus
l'UPAC s'occupe de payer tous les frais
de scolarité P2 institutions est-ce que
je souhaite c'est que ce modèle là
puisse être accessible aussi par les
autres services de police pour qu'ils
puissent aller chercher ce type de
personne pour faire des enquêtes
spécialisées je pense qu'on a besoin au
Québec a donc réglé une partie de son
problème de pénurie de personnel elle
qui souhaite ne plus avoir recours à des
prix de service des organisations
policières pour former ces équipes ici
Pascal robidart Radio-Canada Montréal
[Musique]